[Music]
all right
celebrity gossip time oh my favorite
my family yeah so we did mention this
couple
when we were filming yesterday but let's
go in depth here
shia labouffy again no but in that
in that video this couple was mentioned
i found out what movie i was talking
about tax collector
uh our homies the padilla michael they
work at the shop where he got tatted
oh sick i heard he was like only for
like a second they showed that tattoo
oh that's crazy but he got like a real
action yeah he got a full-on tattoo
oh i remember i remember is the one that
tatted him no yeah yeah he's like all
mexican
style and it was only in it for a second
yeah yeah the guy barbara was the one
that did it it wasn't wasn't it his
parents or something like
it means something to him though oh
probably he grew up in l.a super
la chicano in that culture yeah but no
charla buff was a chicano no he's super
into that culture
oh okay we're not talking about shiat
here though oh we're talking about
olivia wilde and harry styles and how
now they're a couple
but the drama around this isn't she way
older than him yeah
isn't she married to john krasinski or
some [ __ ] no no uh
oh yeah i like him he's funny yeah oh
here so i would like to see
so she is 36. yes 36.
oh she looks good 26. oh get it girl
get it girl good for him yes well no but
we always like to do that
when the because the older women get
with the younger men oh okay okay
wait isn't he dating into person wait
which one's more famous
that's kind of what i'm like say harry
styles he's more famous
and what is harry styles famous for one
direction one direction are you serious
right now dude
do i look like a one direction fan of
you dude you should everyone i'm
wondering
me too this is where one direction fan
looks like well um
okay like is it comparing apples to
apples though because he's like more
music
and like and she's an actress and also
like right now she's doing like director
stuff and like she has
yeah yeah yeah or something and okay
well we'll get into that but
uh styles is for sure way more uh has
more celebrity than her i think so too
yeah i think so too he's more celebrity
so she got
someone that was better but probably
yeah
okay what's the drama wait so she was
with she was with jason's today yeah so
she was with jason sudeikis here so he's
45.
no one wants that oh geezer they
actually have two kids together
a six-year-old and a four-year-old i
believe and they've been together
sin uh for seven years they've been
engaged
practically this whole time so they
actually haven't gotten married
so they're almost done they've been on
the fence for seven years
well so they got they met november
that's some crazy [ __ ] they had two kids
while on the fence
i know right i still don't know so they
met november 2011
and they got engaged uh the holidays of
2012
and ever since then they've been
together but they just haven't tied them
because of corona
2012 hey is that a pocket watch though
it is a party watching you got a pocket
watch so what's the problem are they
gonna fight so no so here's the issue
here
so youtube fight yes boxing match the
under card to mayweather
versus versus styles
i doubt it so here's what's happening so
they've been together all this time
right yeah they announced their
separation
back in november and when they announced
the separation they said that they've
been broken up since the beginning of
the year of 2020
and that they've been taking this whole
time to just figure out their separation
and they take forever to
do everything yeah and like to do the
co-parenting thing
or whatever or not like to separate
pretty much they're
claiming like the initial announcement
was that they broke up early 2020
but it didn't get announced to november
okay but another source
is saying that's a lie is that tmz
uh no no like because that was more
credible like a source close to the
couple like that's like your makeup
artist
but they can't trust nobody no of course
not how can you be
so celebrity and not trust people around
wait man where's the drama what's the
let me tell you what they're saying so
this time about their story yeah
so they're saying this other story this
other source is saying that
in reality they have been together up
until october
and that the only reason they broke up
is because
olivia started cheating with harry
oh when they started filming together
when they're
when they started filming so that that
movie that we talked about in the other
video with shia labeouf where
shia was hired to star in olivia wilde's
new movie that she's directing and also
starring in but then he was being a jerk
and then all this like sexual abuse
allegations came up and so she was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] shia i'm firing you i'm
hiring
harry and so they started filming and
then apparently on set is when this like
romance
do you think she was a fan girl and then
she secretly loved one direction and
then she's like oh my god i can't
believe i'm working with harry
and then she's like he makes me feel
like a [ __ ] 13 year old girl again
well according to that source
that is saying that she's she was
cheating or whatever is uh he
they were saying that harry couldn't get
enough of olivia and that he would go to
her trailer a lot
i would touch is the director i gotta
ask questions true yeah that's true
yeah run lines all day and so apparently
if i had a kissing scene i'll be like
can i practice with you first because
you are the one that's gonna make sure
that
you know what you want i am just a
puppet for you both starring together
according like i think from what i
understand they're doing one of those
they're they're both
starring yeah he's a war veteran too
they're adding way more sex scenes now
he's in the battle of dunkirk still
right it's not a real
we saw this dude's childhood like no i
thought he meant like in her new movie
he's gonna be a war veteran i'm like i
don't know i didn't read this nonsense
like maybe you're right he's very
handsome though he's very tempting
yeah i get it are you emptying yeah but
you like you like styles it's very manly
to boyish right like her ex is like
oh yeah he looks like uh like he he
rides cafe racers and
and and that's what demi moore did too
right she dropped bruce willis for
ashley ashton kutcher
yeah yeah wait i thought you was with uh
no this was before
like like i'm young i don't know dad no
those ages are you know
it was like eight years you really
didn't hear about them
[Laughter]
you know 2012 years ago so he aged like
[ __ ] by the way
oh what the [ __ ] if you didn't tell me
how old
harry was he looks like 35. does he this
guy
no if he if he didn't tell me his age if
you're like he's 30 something 30s
dude he looks like a boy he does look
boyish yeah he's got that boyish look
he's older than you but you look older
that's why he that's why he played like
a young man in uh in that
the dunker there the documentary yeah
yeah
so anyway so then with all this
happening and then with the fans finding
out about
their relationship because they actually
attended a wedding
together and they were holding hands and
that's when like the initial news broke
out that they're
a couple and so everyone was like wait
what the [ __ ] what about jason you've
been with him for so long you have two
kids with this man like you're too old
now
she's like she's holding hands with him
with the hairstyles and she's like oh no
i haven't broken up with jason
we're still getting it for you
[Laughter]
[ __ ] unbelievable so so everyone's
hating olivia
just for the simple fact that like she's
even moved on whether or not the the
cheating out
do they like him that much is that why
he's likable
is like he plays the good guy
nice guy yeah yeah so i don't know like
apparently he's very lovable to the
point where people are hating on her
for even because they like him in movies
and television
i don't even know he's very italian as
much as olivia
like olivia wilde is like way bigger in
my opinion she's wild
she's wow yeah yeah that's where she's
not i get her mixed up with emily blunt
like a [ __ ] what yeah no i'm not
honestly
no i love them both they're not they're
like i mean like i
like emily to me is like her own person
she's amazing she's perfect she's my
favorite actor
she looks like oh wait that's why you
thought it was john kersten's no
if anything i get her mixed up with kyra
nightly that's who i was oh
wait okay i see that what your night
looks way different than her that's
pretty good
well karen knightley got the [ __ ]
eyes though yeah before before all this
drama
we just need to figure out why the [ __ ]
did they not get married for seven years
seven years ago that means she wasn't uh
she wasn't happy you know
yeah well she wanted some young as a
dick yeah yeah he might have asked his
body
she might have asked like 20 times she
wanted a hairless body from a man named
harry that's right that's something
that's coming out of my brain too
but yeah so like um uh oh my god i brain
farted today
no no i prefer where i was going to go
with this oh zach goffin
maybe she didn't want her he's the bad
guy yeah right yeah everyone has a bad
guy
oh i remember now so jason is apparently
just heartbroken about this whole thing
he didn't even know she wanted
out of his really like their
relationship maybe he should have
married her dude
she's so sad she's like you took seven
[ __ ] years
what if he was like hey when are we
gonna get married hey what are we
getting she didn't want no dude imagine
you're with somebody this
[ __ ] hot though you're never doing
better than that is she out of his
league you think
i mean she's just so hot she's in her
own [ __ ] stratosphere you know it's
pretty up there
i mean yes but also can you even think
of a hotter person and name them
she does comedy looks basic to me what
yeah
i don't know i wouldn't put her on a pad
she's she's so to me she's not my type
are you kicking her out of bed joe
[Laughter]
she's not my type she's very exotic
looking but she's not my type of she's
very exotic looking
exotic she looks normal no she looks
white later than me
she looks like a chinese lady with blue
eyes
if i was at huntington beach [ __ ]
shopping at lululemon
that lady yeah that's jennifer addison
yeah you're not wrong
definitely and [ __ ] looking at um
that furniture store
you know that [ __ ] expensive yeah
crate or whatever
she's shopping there so your argument is
that she doesn't look exotic
no cece's swimming all the time and he
goes
up high standards no i mean i
i don't know i think he's the catch i
think jason could get himself
uh equal or no question i'm just saying
she is so goddamn hot i'm saying like
if you were with a perfect [ __ ] 10
almost 11 yeah
i understand why he's upset he's like
god damn that's gonna be hard
well i guess i'm crazy because sometimes
i think a girl is really beautiful
and you guys think she's disgusting but
i'm just like well no one's okay
that never happens it's always us saying
somebody's hot and you saying nah
i don't see it every time yep
you guys got bad taste then but i really
don't think jason's gonna have much
trouble because everyone's like
like at least the fans are all throwing
themselves at him like oh my god jason
you
poor soul i could heal your heart she's
like a very charming guy
yeah that's mad game they want to heal
his dick too yeah they want to gag on
his heart
and hug him and hug his dick the way to
his heart is through his boner
yeah they're trying to suck his heart
out through his dick do you think demi
moore is hot or no
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah oh okay jimmy horse
wants demi
lord
yeah i mean man i don't know dude it
just depends
it just really depends a lot of the
beauty standards in my opinion
are just symmetrical normal looking
human beings that don't have
defects that's all it is i like you
that's what you liked no no like with
the
although i feel like that's how people
find things beautiful it's just like
yeah
and then there's different levels to it
right like there's like you got your
artsy kind
and that you will never [ __ ] but you
know that it's beautiful and then you
have your ones that are like yo she's
disgusting but i want to come in here
people don't want to [ __ ] artsy people
i i don't understand i like artsy people
what i'm trying to say is like there's
beautiful and then there's hot
and then there's like things that make
you horny and then there's things that
you appreciate for the
[Music]
[Music]
symmetry
[Music]
you